depuis 1975 l'interruption de grossesse
est un droit mais elle continue de
bouleverser les consciences des hommes
et des femmes qui sont confrontés c'est
un peu à vous militant je m'adresse
Michel Manso vous êtes écrivains
éditorialistes Marie-Claire et vous avez
été l'une des premières femmes à signer
l'appel des 343 femmes qui ont osé dire
j'ai avorté donc en 1971
ça a commencé par une expérience
personnelle forcément et très tôt et
quand j'entends les femmes parler
aujourd'hui elle ne connaissent pas
cette période où c'était interdit
d'avorter c'était horrible pour moi ça a
commencé au lycée où j'ai eu une amie
dont on parlait parce qu'elle était
enceinte et c'était un événement fou
alors on était au courant du jour où ça
devait se passer dans la chambre de
bonne de son petit ami qui était
étudiant et ça fait pas très bien ce que
ça voulait dire alors j'ai été lui
apporter des gâteaux et l'étudiant a
ouvert la porte c'était plein plein de
sang dans la chambre de bonne et il a
vomi sur les gâteaux enfin c'est une
image que j'oublierai jamais ça c'était
la première fois et puis après ça a été
moi je me suis mariée j'ai eu un fils et
puis j'ai divorcé et j'étais en instance
de divorce longtemps donc avec une vie
de femme quand même et à ce moment-là
c'est à moi que c'est arrivé et j'ai
travaillé à L'Express à ce moment-là il
y avait beaucoup de jeunes femmes de mon
âge et tout on était confronté à ce tous
les mois il y avait un drame et tous les
mois il y avait la recherche des
adresses et on faisait des curetages
sans anesthésie et ça j'ai assisté à ça
aussi c'était une véritable boucherie
enfin c'était des choses d'une violence
qu'on imagine pas et quand on a vu ça
effectivement on peut tout faire pour
que ça cesse
à ça pardon moi je n'ai pas vécu moi
j'ai eu autre chose c'est à dire des
médecins marrons noirs très noirs qui
voulait profiter de la situation et qui
proposait de faire l'avortement mais en
profitant de vous d'abord par exemple
des choses qui étaient vraiment
horribles et profite en nous oui c'était
je crois qu'il y a des histoires comme
ça dans les romans du 19e siècle
c'est une chose révolue heureusement et
beaucoup de femmes n'avaient pas qu'elle
avortait donc c'était la honte il
fallait se cacher c'est des problèmes
qu'on imagine pas aujourd'hui
après j'ai travaillé aux nouvelles
observateur et un jour un homme jambon
qui dirigeait le service documentation
est allé loin de la cause du peuple avec
Simone de Beauvoir et Jean-Paul Sartre
qui ont été arrêtés parce que la cause
du peuple était interdite on les a
emmenés dans des fourgon de police et
puis étant donné leur notoriété on les a
relâchés ce qui a donné l'idée à Jean
Moreau que si on faisait une pétition
avec des femmes qui étaient célèbres qui
osé dire une chose qui contrevenait la
loi mais comme elles étaient célèbres
elles seraient peut-être pas arrêtée
alors il en a parlé au MLF
contacter Simone de Beauvoir qui a
accepté et moi j'ai contacté Jeanne
Moreau qui a eu un réflexe formidable
qui a dit oui tout de suite donc ayant
si vous voulez la caution de ces deux
femmes qui étaient célèbres il n'y a pas
été difficile à prix de trouver d'autres
signatures ce à quoi nous sommes
employés il a fallu convaincre Jean
Daniel le directeur de l'observateur de
publier la pétition ce qu'il a fait ça a
été une grande bataille parce qu'après
Simone va il m'a dit elle-même cette
pétition l'avait aidé à appeler des
Salois c'est-à-dire qu'à partir du
moment où la loi était contrevenue et
désobéitée publiquement sans punition
elle pouvait plaider sa loi à
l'Assemblée
ces avortements ces deux avortements
donc que vous avez subi si vous avez
subi comme une justement une punition
pas du tout non je les ai vécu comme une
libération puisque c'était pas le moment
pour moi on m'aurait pris mon fils
quelquefois c'est des choses Lucie très
factuelle
ne peut pas on peut pas même si on a
envie parce que ça mettra en question la
vie de quelqu'un d'autre ou un autre
couple c'est une question de réflexion
il n'y a pas de règlement on peut pas
dire il faudrait qu'on se prenne la main
dans la main et que on en parle ensemble
l'amour se rapporte de force presque
toujours et le couple c'est une chose
difficile et pourquoi tout d'un coup
cette chose très grave de mettre un
enfant au monde se résoudre dans la
facilité la douceur et la tendresse
c'est aussi quelque chose d'extrêmement
grave qui met en cause la vie de chacun
et Dominique a parlé ici à parler de
manière très raisonnable il a fait un
enfant quand il s'est senti libre de le
faire il a accompagné la première jeune
femme comme à une opération et c'est ce
que c'était pour lui il en a parlé avec
tout à fait la bonne distance il me
semble moi je n'en voudrai pas du tout
si j'avais vu affaire à lui l'avortement
légalisé est-ce que ça donner votre
sexualité la vôtre et celle de toutes
les femmes de l'époque moi je pense que
oui c'était quand même beaucoup plus
agréable de pas avoir peur tous les mois
surtout que comme je l'ai voulu raconter
j'ai vécu ça d'une manière très très
grave et les femmes de ma génération
c'est à dire de qui ont une vécu la
sexualité dans les années 60 enfin leur
jeunesse et la fin de 50 des années 50
c'était horrible parce que la liberté
sexuelle elle était là mais ça n'avait
pas suivi par la pilule donc il y avait
vraiment des problèmes continuels on dit
que le nombre d'avortement le même je le
prends pas du tout je crois qu'il y
avait tellement d'avortement clandestins
qu'on est incapable de dire le chiffre
exact de ce qui se passait avant vous
savez qu'il y avait une femme sur deux
qui dans sa vie quand même à avorter
mais oui mais c'est
très peu par rapport au nombre de fois
chez les femmes ont des rapports sexuels
vous croyez que nombre de femmes ne le
disent pas ah oui je pense que c'est
encore
très très caché et c'est une chose grave
je trouve que les gens qui attaquent ce
droit à l'avortement méprise les femmes
dans leur sens le plus aigu de leur
responsabilité parce qu'il ne faut
jamais ça en l'air il faut jamais
s'habiller de cœur ça laisse des traces
alors les commandos dans les
centres d'IVG il faut vraiment s'y
opposer et ça heureusement une loi a été
votée qui fait que maintenant ils ont un
peu peur mais ils sont quand même très
insidieux le respect de la vie c'est une
notion qui court et qui court et qui
court or il faudrait faire aussi le
respect de l'intelligence et si on nous
a donné
la nature la possibilité de faire des
enfants nous a donné aussi la
possibilité de savoir les avoir quand on
veut donc on nous a tout donné à nous de
jouer sur tous les claviers
pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne Ina
Mireille Dumas abonnez-vous et activez
la cloche
[Musique]